17 dirty diapers strewn around a house?
Absofuckinglutely. People should be embarrassed about that.
The people who were tasked with supporting that mother
in the first few weeks of birthing that baby.
Why is she the one going around the house
to pick up all these fucking diapers?
Why were the fucking diapers left there?
She didn't have that baby by herself.
She didn't. She's not the only one related to.
There's this baby. This baby didn't, like,
hatch from a fucking egg.
There should have been other people around her
helping so that there weren't 17 diapers,
because we're. We're forgetting the fact that
not only did she change the fucking diaper,
now she's the one that's cleaning up after.
She's doing the whole fucking thing.
So who are you to give her shit about when she picked him up?
What the fuck does it matter to you?
What does it matter to you?
And do you know how many times a Newborn baby shits in one day?
17 diapers can be collected pretty quickly
depending on what's going on with the baby and with the mother
and with all that.
But the people who should be embarrassed and ashamed and,
you know,
rethinking their fucking life and decisions for the 17 diapers
is most certainly not that mother,
but every single fucking person around her
that was so excited that she was gonna have a baby.
All the people that showed up to her baby shower and sent Her congrats.
All those people should be fucking mortified.